You know- whether it's a game or not is
another funny thing but I call it a no
player game. I read a book called
Automata Studies, a whole series of
interesting things about automatic
machines, the automaton. In particular,
John von Neumann had been interested in
colonising the planets. You see, you can't
afford to take humans out to the planets;
it's a long way away, you've got to carry
more food and everything than the weight
of the human by a long way. By the way,
you've also got to equip your planet
with an atmosphere and von Neumann's
idea was that you first send some
machines over. His model was that you're
really going to send them to Mars; and
Mars is called the Red Planet,
and that's because it's got a lot of
iron ore, basically rust. And so what
these machines do is initially, well a
whole lot of stages but a big
important stage, is they smelt the iron
ore and get iron. And then, they're quite
clever machines, they start using this
iron ore to build new machines whose job
is to smelt more iron ore and so on.
Not only are you doing that but rust
is iron oxide and so when you separate
this into the iron you get
oxygen out of it,
and so now you can build up an
atmosphere containing oxygen. I don't
think he helped to equip the whole of
Mars with such an atmosphere, but maybe
you have some kind of shell or dome and
in that dome you can have an atmosphere.
And then after considerable time when
these machines have all been
chugging away and
making more machines and so on and
smelting more iron and producing more
oxygen you send the guys over -us, you
know. Then he realised that you had to
have a machine capable of building a
copy of itself, and that seems a bit
difficult.
Maybe in order to build a machine you
need a more complicated machine; and in
order to build that more complicated
machine you still need an even more
complicated machine. But von Neumann
thought no maybe that's not so, and and
he proved it wasn't so. He proved it,
really, I don't know whether he was aware
of this by copying what's done to us
with RNA and DNA. Inside every cell of
your body you've got some RNA molecules
and they contain complete instructions
for building another one, a copy of you. I
call that the tape; you know, so
you have a machine and you put a tape in
this and it builds a copy of whatever
machine is specified by that tape. And
then if you can do that, and it's fairly
easy to do that in a way, you can now
feed it with a copy of its own tape and
then you can build- in that way you can
manage to design a machine and a tape
which will build a copy of that machine
and copy its own tapes as it will build a
copy of itself. Von Neumann's
machine, each
square had 29 states - in the game of life
you only have two states, on and off, or
live and dead whatever you want to call
them. In von Neumann's you had
29 states, if you wanted it to do
something different, to have some other
facility, just added a few more states. In
other words his machine was designed. Now
my life game wasn't designed, I just sort
of thought if you couldn't predict what
it did then probably that's because it
was capable of doing anything.
For about 18 months of coffee times - and
I'm not sure that you know we used- I'm
sure that we didn't use every coffee
time - we tinkered with the rules. The
rules as they finally came out where: if
you have exactly three live- if you're
empty or dead or whatever it is
and you have exactly three live
neighbours then something gets born
there at the next time. If you are alive
and you have two or three live
neighbours then you survive; I
mentioned a birth rule first, to be
born you need exactly three live
neighbours, to survive you need either
two or three.
- (Brady: So there were other)
(iterations of the game, it could have)
(been different?)
- Yeah indeed; you know, what
was different for quite a long time we
tinkered with these rules and finally
came up with the ones I said. And they
really seemed to have very nice
properties, namely didn't seem to be able
to predict what would happen. And
in the end we succeeded in proving
essentially anything could happen, these
things could do any kind of computation you
wanted to do. You could design
configurations that rebuilt themselves
or built more complicated machines than
themselves, all sorts of things.
- (You had)
(no computers when you were doing this)
(early work?)
- No computers at all. After a
time there was a computer which had a
screen, the PDP8, and before it the
PDP7; I've forgotten what those PDPs-
probably the DP is data processing or
something. And then somebody immediately
programmed the game of life for it.
But the initial thinking was all done
before then. I told Martin Gardner about
it, he's the person who ran this
mathematical games column in the
Scientific American for 25 or 30 years. I
thought it would interest people, I
didn't think it would interest people-
his readers as much as it actually did.
Well first of all his first column in
the Scientific American was considerably
before this about hexaflexagons,
and it got more reader mail than any
previous article in the entire hundred
and something year old history of the
magazine up to that time, and so the
editors wanted him to write a monthly
column. And he said he said to me that he
was so broke that he just said yes
before he knew whether he could write a
monthly column. But anyway he wrote that
monthly column very successfully and
then when the life game came up
guess what?
That got more reader correspondence that
anything in the entire history of the
magazine including this hexaflexagon
column. From my point of view though it
wasn't real mathematics. It was
flattering to have so many readers
interested in it and so on and but I I
personally didn't think all that much of
it, but it's nice you know, it's nice to
have other people value something that
you know I didn't really value in a way.
Overall now that I'm getting old I'm
really very pleased that this did happen,
it's one incident in my mathematical
life and I shouldn't be so annoyed about
it and I'm trying not to be.
(Has it been built upon? Is it one of-)
(the mathematics and-)
- No it's
finished. I mean that's another thing
really; you can build upon it in the
following sense, you can study particular
configurations, you can find the
alternative rules that still have the
same properties and so on - but nothing I
think that followed on, it was just as
interesting as the basic fact that this
set of rules did exist fairly simple and
have these astonishing properties which
weren't astonishing to me. Some
configurations just died off, after a
time there's nothing left on the board.
Some configurations seem to go on
forever. Can you tell which of those is
going to happen? Well not really. If you
if you put put a configuration on the
board and follow it and follow it and
follow it, and after a thousand moves it
hasn't died off,
oh well maybe it's going to die off next
move. There's no way of telling, no
algorithmic way of telling whether a
thing is definitely going to die off.
Following it you see doesn't tell you. If
you follow it for a thousand moves and
it hasn't died off yet well maybe it'll
die off in a million moves or a billion
moves or a gazillion moves - whatever that
is. And we do know - and this is not
due to me its a theorem of mathematical
logic dating from the 1930s - the Halting
Problem, there's no way of absolutely
guaranteeing to tell whether a thing
will go on forever or fade away
completely, that's one of the astonishing
properties. You would think that if a
thing is governed by very simple rules
there would be a very simple way of
telling whether this very simple thing
is a consequence of those very simple
rules, but there isn't a way of telling.
(Has the inventor of game of life or)
(people who've studied a deeply have a)
(deeper understanding? Like can you look)
(at a configuration and see something
or does it still baffle you too?)
Well I might be able to
sort of recognise some
little portion of it and say, well that's
not going to have any effect we can
proceed as if that's not there because
it's going to die in 23 moves anyway. But
no in general no you can't. I mean this
condition, you know, you cannot tell is
not a question of not being able to tell
because you haven't got a big enough
brain or something; it is an absolute
condition you know doesn't matter how
clever you are,
there's no guaranteed way of telling.
Okay, I don't hate it.
- (But you don't love it?)
No I don't love it, I really don't.
Yes it made me happy, it's the only one of
those different things. I, you know, I sit
in a corridor in the mathematics
department in Princeton and I think
about things and I imagine that the
young graduate students there
think, you know,
this guy's a loony, he did something good
once and I don't care,
I really don't care.
I've been released from worrying about
what other people think about about me.
I'm often said, I've said for 25 or 30
years, that the one thing I'd really like
to know before I die is-